thank you mr chair thank you esteemed
colleagues
of the smiling county government thank
you for making time for me this morning
i will try to be brief and excited to
take your questions
my fault my glasses fog up so i need to
take my mask off
so i come here today to speak to you
about house bill 1406 relative to
authorizing municipalities to collect
compost
it's a bill that i think is important to
protecting our environment supporting
organic farming improving our state's
farm economies
creating alternative clean energy
sources and helping keep down
the operational costs that our
communities transfer stations
could see
did you know that approximately 40
percent of all food product produced in
the united states goes uneaten
composting is an environmentally sound
practice that benefits our society and
can save new hampshire money in many
ways when we dispose of this food waste
composting is a smart waste management
even the company casella has a new
composting program for anaerobic
digestion anaerobic digestion if you're
not sure what it is occurs naturally in
the absence of oxygen bacteria breaks
down organic matters and produces bio
gas
the process
this reduces the amount of material that
can go into a landfill and produces
biogas which can be used as an energy
source
so how does composting benefit our
society and save new hampshire residents
money
we put less food waste in our trash
therefore folks that take their trash to
a transfer station will have to purchase
less purple bags or per paper bag
reducing
that waste reduces towns
transfer station tipping fees and
therefore reducing overall less solid
waste and
then those less tipping fees
will reduce costs for transfer stations
therefore hopefully not having to
increase property taxes to pay for town
operations like transfer station tipping
fees
it also forges partnerships and
relationships with businesses focused on
utilizing composting like local farm
owners or organic food organic
growth by utilizing the compost which is
rich in nutrients or farms that utilize
compost for certain lives feeding
certain livestock
and lastly it reduces the need for
chemical fertilizers and helps create
healthier food in our growing system
composting and the utilization of food
waste is an action step that i feel is
based on the direction that we found in
some of the findings when this
house
asked the 2019 committee the report on
committee to study recycling streams and
solid waste management in new hampshire
and three of those findings were tied to
composting and food waste utilization
and it's an optional program that this
bill offers the
towns
it allows for the local governance so
that
local control can happen in every town
that feels appropriate whether to
utilize and allows for transfer stations
to have and their local
oversight board to decide if they want
to do this and if how and when they want
to engage in a compost program so i
appreciate you making time for me this
morning i'm glad to take any questions
yes and thank you for your your service
on this bill
my question is
uh whether or not
the towns need this is it re required
can't they do this right now whether
they have this bill or not
my post
i didn't know if you were fine done um
they can
take food waste for compost what they
cannot do now is be authorized to enter
into an agreement with a third party it
could be
a large company like casella to turn it
into
anaerobic digestion like we talked about
it could be a local farm that says we
want to feed our
pigs and we'll manage the compost bin
for you so right now they can say hey we
want a compost but then they have to
figure out what to do with it this would
allow them
with town control to enter into an
agreement with a third party
to execute it
follow up mr chairman
so
uh
there's a rule that
doesn't not allow them to do this that's
i can't understand why the town can't do
this
without the bill that's that's why i'm
maybe not clear of my question
i
based on the rsa that i looked at it it
doesn't allow
transfer stations to make an agreement
on composting it allows them to make an
agreement on reselling their aluminum or
their glass or their cardboard but
because composting hasn't really been a
modern way to reduce waste finally it
has people have realized the value of
composting food waste we haven't we're
basically up updating our our rsas
all right thank you
thank you
good morning representative egan and
thank you for taking my question
um with the program like this whether
it's um
contracted out to a third party or the
town retains maybe a future current
program in composting
is the ownership of the compost always
going to be with the town or does that
also remain negotiable
per
an agreement with a third party
that would be in the agreement if the
the town says
if the town wants to endorse composting
and doesn't want to worry about it they
can say
local farm put a bin here
every tuesday you have to come pick it
up
plain and simple if they want to say
company that's going to utilize this
compost in creating energy you're going
to create revenue from it can we have a
rev share that'll all be decided by the
town how they want to approach it that's
why this is an optional bill it allows
towns to option in
and then they can decide what's right
for their specific
community thank you um is there anything
in um
i guess my first question is how many
towns and cities already have a
composting program
i don't know i
i think part of
the idea is that they don't know if they
can or how they can execute it some of
them have it for
local composting for
shrubbery grass clippings but no one has
really talked about food waste because
you worry about there is always the
concern of okay we're come we're
compiling up food waste and we have to
collect it in a manner that's safe you
know
high fat high high bin so that animals
can't get in
those type of things
so i think it's something that
towns are not aware that they can do
most composting is folks do it at home
they have a compost bin they have a
compost bucket they have a you know i
have a dirt trough
but
when i talked with neighbors about that
i have a trough for composting they said
well what if i live in more of a
suburban neighborhood and i don't i
can't do that or i don't want to do that
can't the town help me with that
and that's where the sort of the
generation of this bill came from that
and the idea that
we're
we should be looking for ways to put
less things into landfills into thinking
about building more landfills maybe make
our landfills last a little longer
you mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um is my understanding with regard to
the bill's framework correct in that
this
bill
is enabling legislation
and therefore the question two
according to um
lines six and seven
the question to either
compost materials at the transfer
station or
to contract
so
will
[Music]
either or
activity be placed
on the warrant
could you clarify that this would be
enabling legislation to do one or of the
or you know one or two of those
actions and that it would
be placed on the warrant correct it
would be enabling legislation that the
oversight board um some towns the select
board oversees the transfer station some
have the town manager that has to go
through the select board some have a
conservation commission
um for instance you know um folks that
i've talked with about this bill
bethlehem has a conservation
commission
so any of those towns would yes
have to put out a warrant or have a
public meeting to say we are going to
enable this alleged it's enabling
legislation you're correct and allow it
to happen and then specifics within that
we're going to enter into agreement
um could you clarify
i understand the part that enabling
legislation it shall be voted upon in
via warrant
an article on the warrant
in your response or reply to my question
you also set a meeting that would not
just be like a regular monthly meeting
it would most definitely be an annual or
a special meeting correct a special
meeting or a town or or the annual town
meeting when warrants would go on
thank you sorry for my
confusion and answer
melvin
i'm a small municipality and we have a
we have a transfer station but we also
compost leaves
and stuff like that can we put that
stuff in the uh
compost pile that we have now
that would be the decision of the
transfer station on how they want to
manage it and and
i think most of them would have a
separate area for food waste
as opposed to
um
what i would call cuttings waste you
know leaves uh branches
grass clippings um sometimes they like
to have them separate
just to basically manage
for you know
animal issues
thank you
representative los alas
i'm a great believer in recycling
um
are you aware that approximately 25 to
30 percent
of
the
waste that goes into a transfer station
is
food waste that could be recycled
yes this is one of the reasons why this
bill is important to me um okay
follow-up
have you ever heard of russian red
wigglers
it's a type of worm i presume yes
russian red wigglers
are
russian worms
that do nothing but
breed and eat
and they just multiply like crazy
and they eat food waste and turn out
compost
very rapidly
they're a wonderful thing i've i've had
many in my life
and uh i'm a great believer in it
no thank you for that information i'll
i'll keep that in mind when if and when
this bill passes um to share that with
the town transfer stations that that's a
a way to utilize
the compost and process it
okay are there any more questions for
this witness
representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative thank you my question i
apologize if this is redundant to
representative powers question but i
can't get my head completely wrapped
around the or
we're we're allowed to i'm just curious
why it's on an and in that sentence
where it says it may collect
or
may contract why why wouldn't we want
why wouldn't you want that to be an and
in there so that you have both of those
things because it seems like then going
to the warrant
we may be asking for one or the other
rather than both together which makes
this the the the i think the goal that
you would like just to i did not want to
i want to give towns local control and
figure out how they wanted to do that
and if they felt that they had an
aggressive compost program that the town
could reutilize the resources they want
to fertilize their ball field or they
have um i'll use my example in grafton
county we have a county farm
could all the towns say this is a way we
want to help reduce costs to the county
and we're going to send them our compost
and the town will collect it themselves
or work with the county to to get it
picked up
or
work with a third party vendor like a
casella or a local
organic farm or a local livestock farm
who will come and manage or manage it
for them i did i wanted to be able to
give transfer station
directors an opportunity to say
i like i want to do this but i don't
have the time or manpower
let me offload it to a third party
and then again last part i want to make
sure that the town knows best what's
good for their community so let their
legislative organization usually select
board that oversees a transfer station
let them decide
how we want to do it and who we want to
do it with
any else questions
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question is
is do you
while i understand that any type of a
program to compost or contract
shall be determined by the legislative
body of the municipality do you happen
to have any estimates
as to
the costs that
might be incurred as a result of a town
to the municipality as a result of a
town
participating in such an endeavor
no because we haven't really done it
before i have there's not a lot of data
research in new hampshire for it
okay
representative gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative uh
to follow up on uh representative
power's question
one of the possibilities for
composting that my town has researched
is a third party
would come in and manage the compost and
not count itself
and then what it does is
uh is that your understanding that what
that would do is reduce the
uh we as a pay-as-you-throw system so
would that reduce the cost of
the blue bags or whatever color bag
right
actually would have a double reduction
it would reduce cost to to taxpayers
to or constituents to buy a bag you know
if you can if you can say great
let's just use the the
national numbers if 40 of my waste is
food
then i use up
i can take 40 out of my blue bag or
purple bag and put it in composting so
that saves the
consumer money
but also if the composting is then
third-party
utilized that's less that's going into
the dumpster and to the town's tipping
fees to a landfill so now it's reducing
costs for all taxpayers whether you
compost or not and the town this was the
idea
of giving them an opportunity to explore
this
um so that actually they could save
themselves money and if they
third party have some type of revenue
generation then they're making money on
stuff that they normally were spending
money to get rid of
thank you
representative
thank you and thank you for taking my
question representative egan
you may remember from the hearing of hb
1185 yesterday
that the town of merrimack composts its
sludge from its wastewater treatment
center we take sludge from
the state through from the franklin
wastewater treatment plant and from many
communities surrounding merrimack
would you believe that that is composted
with sawdust and we make nearly a
million dollars off of that every year
we contract with a company that sells it
as soil amendments for golf courses and
parks and all sorts of places so i'm
very excited about this bill
i'm a huge
home
composter as well i have it down to a
science so thank you for bringing it i
uh to answer her question i i would be
excited to know i would not i would not
be surprised to know that it's a million
dollars um i did have the pleasure of so
i do have the pleasure of serving on uh
as well fish and game on resources
recreation development where we had a
conversation about sludge compost mixed
with
sawdust and potentially
this could also this opportunity could
solve other problems for loggers with
chipwood in the north country who are
struggling to figure out since we don't
have biomass plants anymore how can we
monetize our chipwood the leftover waste
wood when they make logs so i'm not
surprised by this i think we're we're
modernizing the way that we try to
deal with
solid waste and i think it's a
important thing that we're doing for our
constituents and it's a point thing that
we're doing for our environment and it's
an important thing for new hampshire so
i hope i answered your question i
appreciate it
are there any other questions
um i have one um
i maybe i missed something that you said
on here but the cost of
running the compost and i i think you
may need a uh an employee
uh or whatever the other costs would be
do you think they are well worth the i i
believe in this but do you think they
were well worth
the effort to create one i
did not go into this lightly i spoke
with the transportation directors in my
district at franconia which is franconia
easton and sugar hill i spoke to the
transfer station director in lisbon
lisbon lyman
landaf i spoke to the transfer station
director in littleton which isn't even
my district but it's sort of my local
community um and and they don't actually
have a transfer station but they have a
sort of a
trash management person in the town of
monroe which is also my district they
all said that if we were able we're
already separating out
the trash
paper cardboard bottles cans
you know you pay for electronics we're
already doing this so the manpower is
already there it's another bin that we
have to set up
and if we're given the option that
someone else can
bring the bin in
come pick it up empty it bring it give
us a fresh bin
then we don't even have to worry about
it like we have to package up the
cardboard package up the paper
so
it does have a
fiscal benefit for the town
without adding
to their manpower they're already on
site doing this it's just another it's
another thing that the consumer the
resident has to separate
okay thank you
any other questions
all right thank you very much i really
appreciate the time i really appreciate
the questions and thank you for your
time today
i'm going to call now uh catherine heck
from nhme
hi thank you for coming today
uh
no you're not the red button i apologize
my name is catherine heck from the new
hampshire municipal association and i'm
here to support this legislation i don't
want to repeat any compelling testimony
that representative egan has already
given however this does expand local
control and clarifies the law to allow
municipalities to engage in this
composting activity if they choose to
dozens of municipalities are already
looking to do some form of this or
engaging in some local form of this or
researching it as an option to reduce
landfill
costs and offer more environmentally
friendly options to their community
i don't pretend to be an expert in
transfer station management but i do
know there's best practices and
modernization that's constantly being
looked at in order to have a more
sustainable landfill in the future for
our residents as well as save money for
our taxpayers
thank you
are there any questions
for katherine here
representative
thank you ms hicken thank you for taking
my question
if this bill passes is the new hampshire
municipal association in a position or
do they have resources to support
communities that want to start a
composting program
we
always have resources to help them
through the legal process of working
through the legislative you know the
warrant and the town meeting as well as
putting him in touch with resources such
as other transfer stations who might be
further along in the process
and putting those people together and
having discussions so that people can
learn from one another and as some
communities will be further ahead in
this
discussion whether it's locally or
they're already engaging in some form of
local composting and we always do put
our members together to help them
through these types of
new changes to the law
welcome
are there any other questions
representative melvin
could you tell me or do you have an idea
how the municipalities would handle the
maggots the flies and the bees
i'm sorry sir i do not i am not a
transfer station
expert or a composting i do do it at my
home but i'm not an expert in that area
however i do know there are best
practices and nationwide this is a
growing
trend so i think there are best
practices around that and i can
certainly help find the answer to that
question for you thank you
are there any other questions
i see none thank you very much thank you
for your time
and i would like to call tim
bain
would i pronounce that v a
looks like a n
card oh it is i'm sorry
okay
oh this says eagan sorry about that
um
mike nork from
nhdes
thank you very much for coming today
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee uh for the opportunity to
provide testimony i wasn't actually
planning to speak on this bill i am mike
nork
representing the solid waste management
bureau at the new hampshire department
of environmental services
i serve as the agency's expert on
composting
i'm also heading up a current project to
rewrite the composting regulations for
the state um and so i thought i'd
provide some uh information for the
committee uh just we're not taking a
position on this bill but i just wanted
to clarify a few things i i recognize
that there were some questions from the
committee and i'm happy to
take further questions um but
just one point i wanted to clarify in
this bill
this does not add new
in our view this does not necessarily
add new
authority for municipalities it simply
clarifies the statute because there are
already municipalities engaging in this
activity
the statute rsa149m which is the solid
waste management act that's the that's
the statute that we administer in the
solid waste management program at des
that statue
already states in rsa 149 m17
that a municipality has the ability to
sort and separate its waste and create
bylaws to
essentially
run its transfer station manage its
solid waste within its jurisdiction it
also has language that potentially could
be updated but currently it says that
the the town may enter into a contract
with a hauler or a disposal facility
for disposal of solid waste
we've been interpreting that pretty
broadly to mean that they could entered
a contract with a recycling company they
could enter into a contract with waste
management casella you know any of these
companies that run landfills
and also with composting operations and
there are municipalities
that do
currently
contract with
composting companies to pick up compost
throughout the town or to work with
their transfer station where it's
collected and then that company comes in
and takes it to their composting
facility
one of the things i want to clarify
this bill does not
actually create
additional composting infrastructure in
the state and that's where our biggest
challenge is in the state we currently
have i believe
10 permitted composting facilities in
new hampshire and when i say permitted i
mean they are permitted as
facilities that can compost food waste
the facilities for example represent
representative melvin had talked about
the town already compost leaves and yard
waste that's
not regulated by des
that's a permit exempt activity there's
no
it's not a solid waste activity um
because of a
little quirk in the statute it actually
exempts that activity
um but for composting of solid waste
which includes food waste
we do regulate that and any facility
that receives food waste
to compost would need to be permitted by
our agency
so that's the challenges is we don't
currently have enough infrastructure in
the state to handle all the food waste
that could potentially be diverted
and so one of the things that we are
trying to do is revise our composting
regulations
so that we can hopefully make the
permitting process a little bit clearer
simpler and easier for folks to approach
so that they can hopefully
develop more infrastructure in the state
so those are the points i just wanted to
clarify
the other thing i believe representative
melvin had asked about how do you manage
you know pests like flies
rodents birds
the composting process is both an art
and a science
and
part of it is just really it's about the
management of the process and so as long
as you have all the elements in place
for an uh what's known as an aerobic
composting process
that will actually
reduce the chance that you
create odors attract
pests and you know create potential
situations where
you would be creating nuisances for your
neighbors and things like that so it's
really about how you manage the process
and making sure that you have the right
balance of materials it's really about
the recipe and how you manage it
so i'll leave it at that if if there are
any further questions that i might be
able to answer i'm happy to do that i
don't have any written testimony okay
are there any
questions i'm representative wrong
thank you mr norton thank you for taking
my question you talked about the des
permits composting facilities
can you give me some examples of the
criteria of that and specifically
would a composting facility that exists
at the merrimack wastewater treatment
plant would that qualify to take food
waste or is it or is that
the the permitting process for
composting distinguish between the type
of waste that's being composted like
biosolids versus food waste
thank you representative wrong that's a
great question um
just like leaf and yard waste composting
is not regulated by us sludge composting
is also
not regulated by our program that's
actually regulated by
the water division at the es because the
sludge is a result of
wastewater treatment processes
so that's actually a separate permitting
process which is through a different
program at the es is the the residuals
management program
currently
how this works is a facility that
already composts sludge if they wanted
to add food waste
it would require
some sort of
coordination between our programs to
make sure that
the facility is
operating in compliance with both the
rules that govern sludge composting and
also the rules that govern food waste
composting because they are separate
programs
in practice
this is not something that happens in
the industry typically
partly because sludge composting and
food waste composting they try to keep
those things separate primarily because
the end uses can be very different
sludge composting is going to have
more restrictions around where it can be
used just because of the nature of how
it concentrates heavy metals and other
things that could be a potential concern
for human contact
so there's there's a more stringent
process for sludge composting
and food waste composting has a separate
set of criteria
okay are there any other questions
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so you had
commented that composting is an art as
well as a science
my question is what resources are
available to municipalities
who
might choose to
effectively and safely collect compost
thank you representative power that's a
great question that's one that we get a
lot and one of the things that's been
challenging for the department is
and i feel like i'm a brokered record
when i'm in front of environment and
agriculture because i have to
unfortunately the resources that the
department itself has are very limited
for outreach and education
that is part of our charge but it's been
something that we're challenged to do
just because we've been
subject to a number of budget
constraints over the years
we do what we can we also work with
other partner organizations in the
region
such as the northeast resource recovery
association or nra which is actually
it's a organization that works with
municipalities throughout new hampshire
and also throughout new england
on recycling and waste waste management
issues
we also partner with other regional
organizations like the northeast
recycling council which has been trying
to
promote composting
more broadly
i actually serve on the board of the
northeast recycling council so
you know it's a great networking
opportunity and that organization also
provides information and
connects folks with a potential
consultants or other resources that
might be available to help them with
kind of the technical aspects
long term one of my goals would be for
the department to be able to take a more
central role in that
but we are slowly trying to build up a
program that would allow us to do that
we're just not there yet
okay make it quick because we're a
little bit behind
um with regard to you had
mentioned that
because this type of composting is is
food or solid waste composting it is and
requires a permit by your
the department of environmental services
does that also
imply that there would be some type of
inspection
of these
operations
thank you for the question
representative power
so yeah as a permitted facility they
would be subject to audit to inspection
as necessary
it's not something that we necessarily
do on a routine basis but if there's an
issue or a complaint we may investigate
it
um
anything any facility that's kind of
under our jurisdiction
that that would be you know a
a potential option
we try to we try to regulate these
facilities through
you know education rather than through
enforcement
okay is there any other questions for
this witness
thank you very much thank you for your
time
is there anybody else that would like to
testify
i see none i close hearing 14 house bill
1406.
and we are running behind so i'd like to
open up the hearing
for hb 1055.
that's my thing sorry do you want me to
hand it to you
it would be nice thank you
okay great
okay representative duchess would like
to introduce you bill yep uh thank you
mr chairman thank you to the committee
for uh for entertaining me this morning
um
i'm here to introduce a bill i prime
sponsored house bill 1055. this
legislation is very simple the bill
increases the income and asset
eligibility criteria for the property
tax exemption for disabled persons and
for deaf or severely hearing impaired
persons the adjustment for income and
asset eligibility criteria for the
property tax exemption set fourth in
house bill 1055 is based upon the rate
of inflation from 2008 to 2021. 2008 was
chosen as a beginning year because
that's when the rsa was last changed and
i chose 2021 because that was when i
wrote the bill last year and that's the
numbers for inflation that we currently
have
i would also like to recommend an
amendment to the legislation um
that i had drafted from ols it would be
um adding language to change the 15 000
figure in rsa 72 colon 37 which
regulates the exemption for blind
individuals uh change that fifteen
thousand dollar figure to twenty two
thousand dollars a year which would be
the same exact adjustment for inflation
from 2008 to uh 20 i believe actually
was 2003 to uh yep based on inflation
from 2003 when rsa 72 colon 37 was last
amended to 2021. i overlooked the the uh
the blind tax exemption when writing
1055 and only considered individuals
with disabilities or those who are deaf
or severely hearing impaired lastly i
believe the overall cost of the tax
burden shifting will be so many school
that property taxpayers will either not
be affected or will not even be noticed
you can look up the number of
communities that offer this tax
exemption and the number of individuals
who take advantage of it and typically
it tends to be each community maybe a
handful of people so any kind of a
increase would not create an overall
burden for the entire community
and to help mitigate any of these
possible costs too i made the
legislation go into effect on january
1st 2023 and i gave communities a three
years to phase in potential costs just
as the legislation was originally
written and originally implemented back
about a decade and a half ago and um
with that i'll remain open to any
questions and mr chairman after if you
don't mind if i submit the amendment to
you absolutely you can submit that to
the clerk thank
our you power
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative
so um my question pertains to lines 25
and 26
of the bill bill language
so according to the 2020 exemptions and
tax credits summary report
authorized by the new hampshire
department of revenue administration
municipal and property division
residency requirements to be eligible
for all other exemptions and tax credits
is either three or five years
could you please explain what is your
rationale for the proposed change from
at least um
five
for at least five years to at least one
year yeah but thank you for asking the
question representative and i should
have touched on that my testimony and
part of my reason was because if someone
has moved to the state and bought a
house and owns a home and has lived here
as a full-time resident for a year i
feel as if they're pretty involved in
the community that they're going to be a
long-term taxpayer in the community and
i also felt as if the five year i
believe it was five years yep the five
years that was required before was a
large barrier to people
who have disabilities uh from moving to
the state or from retiring in this state
um there really is uh the five years
seem to be a fairly arbitrary number
that was originally established in state
statute i feel a year is more than
enough time to really determine if
someone's going to move to a community
full time be a full-time taxpayer there
and be a full-time contributor in that
community
representatives
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
can you explain to me
a little bit more full fully what leads
you to believe that a year is enough
time to tell if somebody is going to be
a long-term member of the community
what's your thinking behind that
well i would assume in in my in my
assumption i would assume if um
if someone is going to take the time to
search out a community
to you know possibly hire a realtor to
help them either buy land and build a
house or to buy a house and then to you
know completely move their entire family
or you know whoever is in their living
unit with them to a new community and to
essentially you know establish residency
there i would find that you know if
you've done that whole process and then
spent a year right declaring a place
here uh your residence i would feel as
if you know someone's probably fairly
well committed to uh to that community
probably really enjoys it is probably
very excited to stay there and to be a
a part of that community
thank you very much
uh representative majori
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question i
think i'm kind of a broken record on
this but i'm reading down and i
apologize my bill doesn't have the line
numbers on it but it's uh number three
present a procedure for adoption
and in there it talks and this isn't a
change of the bill this is existing
legislation it says the net asset
amounts provided in sections one and two
this act
uh maybe phased in over a three-year
period so i go back to the question that
was asked before
do you see any issue with a community
that is allowing for one year when the
phase in is three years
and shouldn't there be should there be
some consistency there
um
i'm just looking for for areas where
that could be a problem for a community
does the question make any sense
yeah yeah the question does make uh that
makes perfect sense um so
that's a very good question
representative and um how i would kind
of think about it is um if if a
community so obviously people can
already qualify for this tax credit
right and so the three years of phased
in would be the uh the max amount so
someone all this would do would say the
current tax credit that people could
already qualify for that they would be
able to qualify you know in the first
year and as communities phase into the
full tax credit right um
you know then people would the people
who had already qualified in the one
year for the current tax credit but then
eventually over you know the time period
the three years that's phased in within
phase in for the full tax credit right
so it just would get more people you
know taking advantage of the tax credits
sooner right now maybe it wouldn't be
the full amount of the tax credit of
what this bill will have municipalities
doing three years down the road but it
just will get more people you know into
the tax credit
thank you
are there any other questions to this
witness
our representative guthrie thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question in line with the previous
question
uh could you tell me how much is the
exemption
how much ex
exception
these people who qualify get is a
that's a good question i'm pretty sure
if i'm not mistaken off my memory um i'm
pretty sure it's based on the
community's decision but i could be
mistaken on that so i'll i'll write down
that and i'll uh i'll get back to you to
see how much communities have discretion
over it it's a set amount
if i may i'm sorry
yes if i could thank you mr chairman
my understanding is usually when it's an
exemption it's a set figure i just
wanted to know how much of an impact
this would have
uh if it was
it when it is adopted
well i think um as for impact it really
depends on the community and how many
people take advantage of it but i agree
you know that's that figure would be
very important to know so i'll be sure
to follow up with an email and get back
to your representative thank you
appreciate it thank you mr chairman are
there any other questions representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my call
um
i'm an alderman in nashua and every time
i see something about exemptions my
my hackles go up because i i know this
gets passed on but in looking at your
particular bill here because you're
raising the minimum some place like
nashua has um on the on the disability
we have
um fifty thousand and a hundred and
fifty thousand for for assets so this
would not affect us and
where our exemptions um
i i i know for our i think our blind our
blind exemption is 94 and 194 000 for
for disability
um
i guess my question to you is do you
know offhand
how many municipalities will be affected
by this so as i said the the city of
nashville would not be affected by
by your bill here but do you know how
many i know the dra puts up
an alpha list of every single community
county etc have you looked at that and
seen which
what communities will be impacted by
this
it's kind of well i've gone so i have
gone through the dra list and um it's
kind of
it's kind of tough to tell because you'd
have to look at you know the local
community's budgets and how much revenue
they collect
so that's kind of it's pretty
indeterminate it would be you know each
community and you know i would encourage
representatives to look at how it might
affect their community by going through
those dra
numbers and contacting their budget
committee or their board of selectmen to
really kind of go through that but i'd
say for the most part because of the
number you know how small of a
percentage of the total population in
each community what actually takes
advantage of this tax exemption um
it would be
it would be almost minuscule tiny onto
the total revenues of the community
follow up mr chair go ahead which
follows
thank you um i guess i i worded it wrong
i i haven't
gone through every
income of it i guess what i was asking
are are there any communities right now
that are literally just within the state
minimum
that would have to raise this i guess
that's the question oh yeah i mean yeah
there's a number of communities i
haven't looked at the exact number of
communities but yeah there are there are
there are some communities that you know
have a lot more of um of you know of the
i'm sorry what's the word i'm looking
for of um
being able to like and have someone into
the program but there are some
communities that do use the uh the very
bottom number and have since the statute
was you know last last updated in 2008
and for the blind exemption 2003. so um
i think the overall purpose of this bill
though is that if communities have
adopted that program that because of
inflation over the last 15 years you
know we should make sure that their
adjustments made because there are
people who theoretically could have
previously qualified for this program
right and did and now you know we're 15
years later and they're either getting
very close to no longer qualifying or
they just no longer qualify anymore
just one quick follow-ups mister go
ahead thank you so much
this still remains enabling it's not
going to force any of the communities
that don't have this type of um
correction
correct yeah yeah there's um there are
communities across the state that don't
that don't utilize this um if the
community decided that this adjustment
now is not right for their community
they could they could no longer offer
the exemption i will say though to that
note that was one of my concerns when i
first um you know when i wrote it
introduced it and then kind of thought
about it because obviously sometimes you
have that thought in the middle of the
night where you go well how would it
affect this um i spoke to the new
hampshire disabilities rights center
new hampshire disability rights center
they support the bill and the amendment
and their concern regarding that point
was um very limited i brought that up to
them they hadn't even really considered
it but i said you know is this something
that um that could possibly concern you
if raising this makes communities less
involved in this tax exemption program
and they said that they didn't really
foresee that being a large issue
especially because they believed in
after them you know compiling some of
the dra numbers that it would be such a
small fiscal impact that most voters
wouldn't be in an
uproar for something that probably
wouldn't even affect their overall tax
uh their tax bill thank you very much
are there any other questions for this
witness
okay sir mr representative thank you
very much your testimony thank you for
having me
do we have anybody else from the
audience who wanted to testify in this
bill
okay i see none i'm going to close the
hearing
on house bill 1055
and we will open a hearing on 10 69 at
10 o'clock
i believe
i'll get back to you with an email
thank you
okay we have holly stevens on um house
bill
1055 is in favor
from concord
thank you sir all right good thank you
yes
anybody want to use the sanitary
facilities uh
is please
is
many people got a copy of the amendment
from the last bill
okay
what time are you
that's great
thank you very much
that's great thank you very much
um
i have no idea
okay
and this is just a village
i don't fully understand
that
pull them out
representative
don't order too many of them
i should have waited right
thank you
my
versus having is committee member
whatever i yes
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee i'm norman zilber
a state representative from belknap
county district 2 to the towns of
guilford and meredith
i happen to live in the town of guilford
i'm not wearing a mask for those of you
who are concerned about masking i'm not
wearing a mask because i had covert a
year ago
my doctor tells me i have a very high
level of natural immunity antibodies so
that's why i'm not wearing a mask
currently
everyone i'm assuming that a large
number of people who come before you
with bills say this is really a simple
bill how many times have you heard that
okay
this is really a simple bill
existing rsa 670 colon 2
under the chapter 670 dealing with
village district elections provides that
voters in each village district elect at
an annual meeting
three commissioners
some officers but basically three
commissioners who run the district from
day to day
there's been a prior
modification of that
which allows
the uh the towns of merrimack and
hooksett
to elect up to five commissioners if
they so desire
in belknap county we have at least one
village district that is
limited to three
commissioners
and the the practical problem is that
sometimes it's difficult to get a quorum
to get at least the two of those people
to show up particularly in the
wintertime when
people may be traveling out of state and
things like that
so the purpose of my bill is to
[Music]
modify 670 colon 2 sub a
which adds belknap county to the towns
of merrimack and hooksett
allowing
them all to elect up to five
commissioners
and that would then make it a little
easier to on a practical level to run
day to day
to
have a quorum and to conduct business
the interest of full and fair disclosure
i briefly served as a commissioner
in the water district in my town in
gunstock acres
until i was told that it was an
incompatible office that i couldn't
serve there and on the budget committee
so i
resigned from the the village district
but the water district in
guildford acre gunstock acres serves
over 500 homes and two commercial
establishments
it's got numerous wells pumping stations
treatment facilities etc etc uh and it's
a very complex computer system
and
it requires
uh people for whatever
relatively nominal pay they get to
service commissioners
to really one run the water system even
though there's a contract with a private
operator who runs a day-to-day the
commissioners do oversight and they make
decisions so this is this is as i said
pretty simple it just basically allows
doesn't require them but it allows them
to elect to
increase the number of commissioners
from three to five it's very simple
and as i said this is sort of the i
believe the epitome of a simple
housekeeping bill and i'll be happy to
answer any questions if i can
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question so
my question pertains to the language in
the bill on lines
22 and 23.
and specifically your amended language
states that for which the chain shall
take place
immediately upon receipt of the
requisite number of referring
affirmative votes for the proposed
change so my question is what is the
rationale for this language and and
stating that the the change shall take
place immediately and as opposed to
the
current language in the bill in line 21
as stipulated
basically it's to
get the change done right away
they're short-handed and if they have to
wait for the next annual meeting
and it was basically if this passes
my what i would envision they would call
a special meeting of the district notify
all the voters in the district and then
make a proposal to adopt this change and
then elect two more commissioners if
they had to wait without that language
if they had to wait till the next annual
meeting they would still be they would
be shorthand for that period of time
could be as long as a year
thank you
representative silber for taking my
question
following up on representative powers
this new language on lines 22 224 would
require then
the additional time and expense of
calling an additional meeting
since the affirmative vote would take
place at one annual meeting but if it's
going to be effective immediately
um there would have to be would there
have to be an additional meeting to
elect those that would be a special
meeting yes and the the only expense
involved would be
the notification by regular snail mail
which has not been very good in belknap
county recently
and elsewhere or by email there's a lot
of email uh basically uh in in this
particular district with which i'm most
familiar
uh virtually all of the residents who
are in the district have given their
email address and that's used for
notification of water outages and
notices of meetings and things of that
sort so it's really a fairly nominal
expense
and and the meetings are typically held
at the guilford public library which
does not charge anything for the use of
the meeting room
follow up
thank you
um well i i represent merrimack which is
one of the communities we and and we
have five commissioners
why would not this bill address all
counties and give them the option
because it's not making it mandatory
they go to five commissioners it's still
they can adopt up to five is that
correct
that is correct it is optional
and the reason that i drafted this the
way that i did was
i wanted to
try to make this
the possible as opposed to
trying to sweep
a very broad brush i was only dealing
with this was done at the request of a
constituent group
and i did not feel like i wanted to
drag other parts of the state into this
issue if they were not interested but if
if the committee
felt that this would be better
legislation just to
let everybody elect to have five
i would certainly support that
okay thank you very much
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
is the belknap county commission more
shorthanded than other county
commissions around the state
this is not the belknap county
commission this is the village district
pardon me is the village district
commission more short-handed than other
such districts in the state that was the
answer you gave to a previous question
so my question is
do you know anything about other
districts
all i can assume thank you thank you for
the question all i kind of assume is
that other than
the two towns that are already allowed
to go merrimack and hooksett
that everyone else is limited to three
and
i haven't heard from anyone
of any other towns or any other
districts
that we've got a big problem but maybe
they do and maybe they don't know how to
address it or they don't want to address
it i i can't
speculate on their motivation
but you know we all know that
serving as a commissioner on a village
district is basically a volunteer
position
it's hard enough to get volunteers even
if they're paid something there's
usually not a lot
and a lot of the people who do volunteer
i would assume many of them
like some of my neighbors
leave during the winter time and they go
to florida or arizona or north carolina
wherever and during that period of time
during the heart of the winter which is
when
pipes for example in a water district
when pipes break when you really need
action taken
they may not have a majority of you know
a quorum present if they only have three
commissioners so i but the answer is i
don't know the answer sorry
representative gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um i my question is about the mechanics
of how this works
if the village district chooses to
increase from three to five
where do those new candidates get voted
on
how can it be at this at the same
meeting there would be an advertisement
it would be public notice of the meeting
as well as indicating that this meeting
was going to be held to consider
increasing and to accept
statements of interest or applications
for people wishing to be considered as
candidates would be done at the same
meeting
that's fine but if the
um
the village district
declines increasing to five
then
they would choose from the five
candidates
i'm sorry i'm not sure
could you restate that for me please i'm
sorry
yes if on the village district uh the
village district declines to increase to
five commissioners
um
and they're stuck with three
okay they're stuck with three but they
have five names to choose from i'm sorry
they're stuck with three but may have
five candidates to choose from but no
there was those three that they they go
into the meeting with three
commissioners
those commissioners have typically have
staggered terms
and so
the only time that any of those three
would be replaced potentially or
reappointed would be when their terms
expired so
if there's a special meeting call to to
vote on an increase from three to five
and it's voted down
they would just continue with the three
people until their terms expire
thank you representative
thank you mr chair um
um
recently in the the city of um of
nashville we um
i'm over here
i'm looking around trying to find where
the voice is coming from
i should have raised my hand
we recently tried to increase our border
health from three to five um we we ran
into um a problem with the current board
who felt that they worked really well
with just three and the reason we tried
to do it was because of much what you
said quorum was becoming an issue during
covid appointments and and so on and so
forth so my question to you is
how do the current commissioners feel
about having an increase of two more
bodies that they have to get approval or
non-approval or so on this this was
thanks for the question this was
specifically introduced by me at the
request of the existing commissioners at
least one of whom is here today
that answers my question and i saw him
raising his hand behind you because he
truly wanted to answer that so thank you
so much you're welcome
our representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
i i just want to make sure i'm not
seeing an inconsistency you say that
there there may be a special meeting to
do this and that the change would take
place immediately i think i understood
that correctly yes but as i read section
e and again i apologize for not having
line numbers but it's at the end
it says the additional commissioner
position shall be filled by a village
district vote at the annual meeting
is that inconsistent with the change
that would happen immediately or am i
just
not understanding it correctly
which i always default to i don't
understand
because i'm married and i have three
kids and that's what they tell me
you know
i would like to say that i drafted this
but i asked ols to draft this
so uh
and
there appear yes i can see where
there might be
a
uh an inconsistency
except that you know we should go back
to the earlier section roman numeral
four
that bellam county the change would take
place immediately upon receive the
requisite number of affirmative votes
for the proposed change
so
the change would take place
but then the so that then you would have
a five member commission with only three
appointed and then the next two would be
potentially appointed at the next annual
meeting that's what i would read it
i don't know if that answers your
question oh it does i just want to make
sure that i'm not misunderstanding it
because i could if i always default to
if i'm confused that somebody else might
be but usually it's just me no i i don't
think it's you in this case sir okay
thank you any other questions
representative silver i've been kind of
marinating on marinating on that same
section and i i do have an issue with
having it immediately enacted and
electing those additional two
commissioners at the meeting because
and correct me if i'm wrong but i think
under present rsa there needs to be
notice for those positions before the
election
but you can't notice them if they don't
exist
so
one of the things i'd like your input or
your response to
if it is
approved immediately or enacted
immediately on majority vote
that those additional two commissioners
be appointed for the remainder of the
term that's described and then elected
at the following annual meeting the way
we fill vacancies now for town and
school positions
that might be a recommendation
i might
you know ask you to consider
so treat them
if it's approved for the additional two
treat those two as
positions that need to be appointed for
the remainder of a term until the next
annual meeting
i have a serious concern about adding
the um in merrimack anyway it's
expensive to have an annual meeting and
our village district we're lucky if we
get 10 people out of a population of 27
000 to go and that's for the regular
annual meeting if we had a special
annual meeting
i doubt we would get anyone there um of
course merrimack wouldn't have to do
that because they're already yeah we're
already at five already at five right
and i hope we are the only town that has
difficulty attracting people to our
village district meeting
the
excuse me the
the notice the public notice under 91a
of the special meeting it would be
posted in mail to all the members the
voters in the in the village district
would state that there's going to be a
special meeting
to consider increasing the number of
commissioners from three to five
and
anyone wishing to be considered for
appointment or election as a village
commissioner
should submit their applications 48
hours prior to the meeting something of
that sort if you look at lines 25
it says if the village district votes to
increase the number of commissioners to
five and its commissioners serve
three-year terms at the first annual
meeting following the vote the village
district she'll elect two commissioners
for three-year terms
one commissioner for a one-year term and
then it goes on about the next annual
meeting so i think it's i actually think
it's it's pretty well covered i don't
think there's going to be mechanically
now i've been to the
the village district that i am a member
of or a voter in
and i think we and we're probably lucky
to get 10 or 15 people
um the only time anybody shows up is if
there's a been a problem with the water
because it's a water system that
supplies residential water and if
there's been a problem with the water
system or they want to raise rates or
something like that then we'll get a
larger turnout but ordinarily
and i think the turnouts are fairly
modest
okay are there any other questions for
this witness
i see none thank you very much thank you
members of the
committee i'd like to call
commissioner you very much mr epstein do
you have the testimony you'd like to
submit yes i do respect the chair when
you get through would you just hand it
to the clerk and he'll take care of the
point okay
uh
first of all
we uh i will greet the chair and
respective members
representatives
gun stock acres village water district
is pumping out a little over 4 billion
gallons a year
okay
we are classified by the state of new
hampshire as a
large municipal system
our annual meeting is coming right up on
february 16th
okay and to answer your question there
are two commissioners here and we
already have two additional
commissioners lined up who are ready and
waiting to take the spot
okay
granted we are not as big as hooksett or
merrimack but our system does not rely
on
uh
large ponds we have 14 bedrock wells and
it's much more complex and numerous pump
stations
gunstock acres village water district
needs to maintain continuity of
leadership
what i mean by this is we need to
attract more and quality water
commissioners
to do this we have already raised the
stipend from
annual stipend from five hundred dollars
to a more equitable number okay
uh
this will attract quality leadership who
will be interviewed and be asked to
supply a resume concurrent with the
interview
the commissioners of gunstock acres
village water district each carry the
same responsibilities as the selectmen
in the town of guilford
these responsibilities have become too
much for just three commissioners
we wish to expand to five commissioners
okay
these responsibilities involve
interfacing state regulations with the
new hampshire drinking water bureau
department of
environment filing of numerous forms
with the department of revenue
administration these forms are the same
number as merrimack files
same exact number of forms
additionally gun stock acres water
village district because of the
complexity of the system has to
interface
with
engineering consultants software
consultants water bill management
the list goes on and on and on okay
and the responsibilities go on and on
we do project management grant writing
right to
the law manager we have to have
we respectfully request the passage of
house bill
1069 as amended as written to amend rsa
colon 2a to allow merrimack and hooksett
to have five commissioners but belknap
county as well
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions for this witness
representative galligan
hi um can you just repeat your name for
my nope taking purposes please howard
epstein
okay thanks
are there any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
just hand that into the quest appreciate
it
are there anybody else that would like
to testify on this bill
i see none i'm going to close the
hearing
on house bill 61069
thanks a lot
oh can i get the blue sheet
thank you
okay the blue sheet on that hearing is
uh norm silva representative norm silva
he is for
the bill and joseph gerasi
uh he is also for the bill and he is a
commissioner it looks like for belmont
and that's g-e-r-a-s-i
the next hearing is going to be at 10 30
and it's house bill 1081.
yeah we do
um
foreign
uh
um
so
i guess
is
uh
sorry
i'd like to open uh
house bill 1081.
uh miss representative smith you'd like
to introduce the bill please
thank you mr chairman and fellow
representatives my name is jonathan
smith i represent carroll county
district five which is the towns of
effingham break out effingham brookfield
wakefield and
ossoffy i sent the whole committee an
email going back a few days i don't know
if everyone received it or has a copy in
front of them i don't know if it was
distributed
was it mr chairman do you know i have a
copy i'm sure
um so this is a relatively simple bill
as you've just heard prior to me on my
previous speaker rsa 52 deals with
village districts
um
specifically
the issue here is the dissolution the
former village district under 52-2
meetings to consider
it is a simple majority it doesn't state
that but by default it's a simple
majority because it doesn't mention the
vote count the dissolution vote requires
a two-thirds majority it specifically
states a two-third two-thirds majority
so my bill just changes two thirds a
simple majority
uh to make it even with the ability the
way it's formed in my opinion
and i am a selectman in my town i am the
chair of the board of selectmen
um i've had many people contact me in my
uh town alone we have three fire prisons
in the tiny town of 4 000 people
to be able to dissolve them now it takes
two thirds but when they were formed
many decades ago it was a simple
majority
so
a government entity should never be more
difficult to dissolve than it is to form
it's really that simple
are there any questions
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
like you i'm on the select board in my
town too and
we we have we have the constant
fees expenses that we have for different
things my question to you is when the
district was formed
way back when did they have those fire
districts those three precincts or or
did they have precincts within the
district and i i guess are the districts
within the precinct now or within the
village district now
each precinct is its own village
district each one each one correct okay
i'm sorry i didn't understand that yes
thank you and there's a town i just
elaborate there's a town north of me
who has i believe seven districts
the same scenario and they're talking
about the same process how it's a burden
to dissolve okay thank you so for
representative guthrie thank you mr
chairman
and thank you for your taking my
question i'm not i'm also a selectmen
but it's in hampstead we don't even know
what a village is
so
could you tell me what reason what kind
of reasons
if you would why someone would want to
dissolve
a village district within its
uh
within its town or i don't even know
if i could
mr chairman i don't even know
what the relation is to village
districts to the town in which it's
located
so village districts are used for many
forms for firefighting for water
impoundment and there's a whole gamut if
this is just the cover pace rsa 52
village districts there's probably 25
sections in here i'll have to look it up
yes yeah it's
it's it's a quite complex broad spectrum
of things that it covers
so an example would be you formed the
district to uh
and might use my example we have three
fire precincts these were formed decades
ago the town was uh
much simpler things were much cheaper on
today
the
firefighting is very complex it's very
expensive
so the idea of having three separate
districts
dissolved and being able to form them
into one would in turn produce a much
more efficient way of of setting up
firefighting operations
i think that's just one small example
i understand i think a little bit and i
could did mr chairman thank you
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
in my estimation the establishment of a
village district as a governing body
is
not without significance it's a very
important thing
so
i understand your change from the
two-thirds majority to a simple majority
however if your purpose is to
align the vote threshold
to be the same to establish a village
district as it is to dissolve a village
district
i'd like to know your thoughts and your
consideration with regard to
would you consider
um
having
both
the vote threshold to establish as to to
to dissolve to be two-thirds
because as i stated
it it's it's
it's establishing another body which is
you know governing
the taxpayers and the people could you
come could you respond to that yes um i
would not object to that for newly
formed village districts but again
you've got districts that were formed
decades ago
under different circumstances and to
change it to two-thirds to form
doesn't benefit dissolving the ones that
are in existence now
thank you um mr chair and thank you for
for taking my follow-up question so
therefore you'd be open to such an
amendment but however to grandfather um
pre-existing village districts
to to follow this um your simple
majority
to be consistent with vote thresholds
yes
thank you yes
uh representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
on line three and four where it refers
to the majority of its legal voters
that means of registered voters or of
the voters that came to vote that day so
i can speak to that also i did research
research that because that is always
brought up there is a case
going back to 1960
62 sugar hill improvement association
versus lisbon there is case law that
it's only the voters that are actually
present and participating it's not the
total voting voting base
and i'm sorry could you give me that
citation again sure sugar hill
improvement association versus lisbon it
was from 1962. that's referenced in the
new hampshire planning land use
regulation 2019 2020 edition on page 76
you will see that reference
thank you
representative wrong
thank you rep representative smith and
thank you for taking my question
my concern
my concern with this bill is presently
for a bond to pass under a village
district it requires two-thirds vote is
that correct that is correct okay now in
my in my community of merrimack we
passed a couple bonds a few years ago to
in to construct pfas filtration systems
on
four wells that were not covered under
an agreement with saint-gobain
and they were for
nearly 20 million dollars total
thankfully they they passed but
if a big decision like that
requires two-thirds vote
and weave now all this capital in our
village district millions and millions
of dollars of capital
why would only a sim if it took
two-thirds to to approve it and invest
in it why would it only take a simple
majority to get rid of it
to create the district itself right now
is a simple majority the bonding issue
is a separate issue every bond issued
requires a two-thirds vote or
supermajority by the people i think
monetary expenditures are
have a greater magnitude and impact
immediately
than the idea of dissolving the district
with a simple majority if the people
again to form the district was a simple
majority to dissolve it should be no
more difficult
it's
that's like i said this bill is really
that simple monetary issues are
completely separate from the formation
and
us dissolution chair
anybody else have a question for the
representative
go ahead okay thank you mr chairman but
wouldn't the dissolution also be have a
financial impact because now there is
millions of dollars of capital that's
owned by the district but it only takes
a simple majority
to
impact that investment
assuming it would be a divestment
yes it's it's no the decision is is not
something to be taken lightly it's gonna
have to be a serious discussion you'll
have your public hearings on it
um but again the bottom line is if when
this rsa was drafted and it stated
two-thirds to form i wouldn't even be
here talking to you i'm looking at it
from a point of fairness to the taxpayer
something that was formed 50 years ago
the present day taxpayer if they think
it's not being run properly should be
able to dissolve it as easy as it was
formed and that's why the simple
majority is the request okay thank you
thank you
okay are there any other questions for
this witness
i see none thank you very much thank you
is there anybody else that would like to
testify
i've seen none so i'm going to close the
hearing
on
house bill 1081
and we have
11 o'clock i believe is the next one
thank you
on the blue sheet
we have
it looks like
mr chester's be the last name from
bedford he's in favor of it james
fellain in favor glenn cordelli
in favor
lino avelino
in favor and mark mccourtney
in favor
they uh
splain was from rocklin too carroll
county
codelli carroll county five
and carroll county six for mccourtney
yes
there was
there was five yes but i'm gonna get the
electronic sheets in a little bit so
they're gonna be different i think
and when i have them i'll pass them out
to you
um
you
oh
friday
all right
oh
now
okay
i'm sorry
oh
rosemary yes
well
i'm not sure
we'll still do homework
research
is
thank you
the next film
five minutes
i'll tell him to check his clock
she's moving
all right
you're awesome
okay
is
that's right
this is
okay
um
yes
uh
i'm self-taught
scary
i've
collected forever
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee i have another uh bill in
another committee in
like 10 minutes so i'm going to be super
quick
the idea of this bill is that
that
when towns ask for money
for roads
they
do not
uh give
the
they do not ask the people
if they also want those roads to
be without
notice shut down or closed for any
reason
and i believe that the townspeople
that shutting those roads down
for
just by the request of some group or a
person
and not the entire town giving the
approval
is essentially and and those towns
granting that closure
is essentially
um
saying we took the money so that you
could travel but then we're going to say
nope you can't use this now and you have
no say in that and so what i'm seeking
to do is give the town's people some say
and say uh give them the opportunity to
say you're not allowed to close down any
of the roads or sidewalks for you know
just because someone asked because they
want to stand there or do whatever they
want to do there's places that um in
town like parks and stuff like that
which are for that purpose
but the purpose of roads is for
traveling not for shutting them down
um
and so that this
this proposal would allow the people of
the town to vote on which roads they
would they would allow to be closed for
um
and for how often
um you know how many days per year or it
would give them a lot of control over
which roads and for how long the roads
are going allowed to be shut
and so
i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you representative and thank you
for taking my question
um are governing boards
compelled to provide uh permission for a
group to um
close a road for instance
i mean so what you're saying is that
governing boards
right now that decision to close a road
or sidewalk is not going to be their
decision it's going to be by vote of the
town
so there there's a um
usually i think it's um you know these
permits are going to be issued by like
the town manager and there are some
guidelines for what for what would be
acceptable for approval so that they
don't run afoul of like free speech laws
and stuff like that we pick this person
can can
you know protest or have a block party
but not that person you know and so they
want to have
um
something
neutral
so that they can grant those permits or
not and i'm saying that
that
the town
really should be the first person to say
okay we're going to say
you know our
our uh residential street is not the
street to be shutting down um and if you
want to shut it down it needs to be on
this street you know the these many days
of the year and then the town can
if they have a request would be able to
grant that
um
that closure
can i have a follow-up
thank you mr chair
so merrimack we have this
um
the big event of the year is a little
league parade right and it's typically
um the last friday i think in um
in april
now there has been a time when we've had
to delay that a week because of weather
or something so are you saying that the
town the voters would have to approve
the first parade
but then they'd have to approve the
rescheduling
so so
all so the per
if if you're talking about
um the little league people are asking
for the road to be closed yes right okay
so
so this wouldn't cover if it was like a
holiday parade because it's the town is
not issuing themselves a
permit right this is closure
from a requested third party like a
private party that's and
and so
you are allowed
if you see in on lines
like 21 20
to 25
of the bill or on the first page
you can
you can set a time frame you could set a
number of days you don't have to say it
has to be you know tuesday the 14th
you know every year
it could be you know you're allowed to
close it close this road one day per
year
right and so it wouldn't matter which
day
they chose it would just be
um
it would be a maximum of one day
for example
but you could also i mean the
townspeople could also say we were we're
okay with you closing it for
up to seven days you know or something
like that and it would be
um
you know then that
so what the towns people are doing are
saying okay we're going to put
this road in the hands
of the legislative or in the hands of
the governing body or oftentimes it's
going to be the town manager
or um that's actually issuing the
permits um
and they would have the flexibility to
say okay we're gonna do one day this day
one day that day
and then if there are requests for you
know eight days and they're only allowed
to issue seven days then they would have
to refuse that eighth day
okay thank you
um
yeah i
so
i live
in a city and
my understanding is that warrant
articles are
more for
municipalities
that are organized as towns rather than
cities i i mean
i've
i've never voted on a warrant article
here as the resident of concord i've
never even been
noticed of one um
so my question is um
would this
would this apply how would this apply
equally to towns and cities and
um if not how
how are they supposed to do things
differently
um yes on page or on online 11 it says
the selectmen of the town or governing
body of the city may grant a license
um
so so yes it would be it would cover
cities and there would
if
i'm not as familiar with the um the
method for the people of
cities to
give give permission to their
their elected officials since i'm in a
town
i wouldn't
representative
thank you thank you chairman and thank
you
representative yokola
the question that i always have when we
get a bill is what's the problem that
this bill is trying to solve
do we have a problem with towns
arbitrarily closing roads all the time
and making it inconvenient for people
what what is the problem that this bill
is trying to solve
thank you thank you i so
there
in
i guess i'll answer it this way i think
that um
the
that the closure of roads
without the approval of the people
is essentially taking their their money
for roads and using it for another
purpose
and so it's essentially fraud
and
the um
while it may be an annoyance to some
people that this road is closed
you know um for one day
they may not
um it may not rise to the level that
they are
um
going to
make a big stink out of it every year
but if they were empowered to set
guidelines for the town they would be
interested in doing so um it from the
comments that i have heard um after
after submitting the bill that people
do get annoyed by the roads being closed
um
so i think that's
i'm not sure that it
rises to the level of like i'm going to
vote you out kind of a thing but yeah
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question so
as i understand the bill you need to in
that warrant article you need to declare
the road
and roads and sidewalks that are going
to be closed so for instance in the town
of in my town where we have a race which
happens to be in a village district
um which is just funny but
uh
we would need to say we're going to
close road a b and we're looking for a
pool for a b c and d
but we also have alternate routes just
in case something happens based on the
area so we would need to delineate
all the potential roads to cover
ourselves is that correct
yes
you would just say i mean you could have
the list every single road in town if
you were okay with every single road
being closed it's up to the town there
they can do whatever they want in their
town right so
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and um thank you
representative for uh taking uh my my
call you you made a comment about that
um
the when uh representative van asked the
question about what was the problem
that's trying to solve you said need
some kind of comment about they take
money for road closure and use it use
that money for another purpose
and therefore being fraud i don't know
if i quite understood that but don't we
kind of do this all the time for like
parking meters we use it for another
thing for
um lottery fun you know we do it for
other things and so on i mean
we set up these these funds sources
these revenue sources to
understand you correctly i apologize
thank you for the question obviously
we're not taking money for road closures
we're taking money for
paving of roads and
um
we have i mean in my town we have worn
articles often or um
even in the budget for road paving and
that the the reason that you have roads
is so that people can travel not so that
they can be closed off
like obviously if it's for safety or
maintenance those those are already um
allowed in this bill this is closure
um by a request of some person
you know or group saying i want
you know main street closed for
for me so that i can you know
have a cat parade or something like that
right and if they if the town is okay
with that that's fine but i think the
town should have a say in whether or not
they're closing off main street you know
for whatever reason
one follow-up yes just a quick follow-up
i guess um
i go back to represent representative
fans question is that
so if they closed it for
one
day for a cat parade i know they
probably wouldn't but if they did for a
cat parade
you're saying that the money that was
used to pave that road
is being used incorrectly even though on
the 364 days
people are traveling on that
is that with you right the townspeople
should have
the the ability to use the roads that
they paid for right if they're not
if they're being hindered from that
that's
without you know a say in the process
that is a problem i see
thank you thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
going back to the what is the problem
that needs to be solved in the existing
statute it limits
the term of the license already
to a very short time
so i'm wondering
you know
is it really that much of a problem
to close a road
and and
last night at our city council meeting
in lebanon we actually had this
discussion
about closing off a street for a period
of some years
so that a restaurant could have outdoor
seating during the summer
and the vote was yes because the city
needs the revenue that the restaurant
produces
so you may be closing off one avenue so
to speak
and
closing off more inadvertently
by doing this
do you think that that could be an
unintended outcome
um it sounds
like
like your town is
is giving
um
or or city is giving uh
the people
some say and whether the roads are
closing so i think that's actually
unusual um but
um i don't think that's that that would
be limited by this because you would
still be able to
to
do that representative uh do you
care to take any more questions i i
really have to go so
i'm already five minutes late i'm not
sure if they
are running on time so
thank you
thank you absolutely
sorry
okay
and now i'd like to call catherine heck
please from nhma
good morning again
my name is catherine heck from the new
hampshire municipal association and we
are here to oppose this bill
we did have some concerns over the
legislative finding as it relates to
the budget and fraudulent expenditures
of money
municipal budget law allows the
governing body to expend up to the
amount in the approved bottom line of
the budget so due to changes in
circumstances or conditions and the
inexact nature of budgeting rsa 3210
corrects that by requiring the governing
body to do a line item transfer which is
transparent so if any funds were somehow
being diverted
which i'm not really sure based on the
testimony now that we have a clearer
intent of the bill
it still would be transparent that some
purpose might have changed through the
line item transfer requirement that the
law provides
additionally the local governing body
under statute has the ability to
determine policy and decisions regarding
the local roads so the requirements of
this bill seem to deviate the governing
body's authority as a local select board
and they would be then unable to make
any decisions about a request until the
town meeting the annual town meeting and
any new requests that came in would have
to wait an entire year for the next town
meeting
so this bill removes local authority
that's already granted to the governing
body to make such decisions
and it is our understanding that
the governing body would have a
permitting process whether it be through
the select board or perhaps a town
manager that would set forth clear
guidelines and that would be
open and available to the public to
weigh in on so thank you
are there any questions
thank you chairman uh thank you
so is it your understanding that the
allegation is here
let's use round numbers i pay a hundred
dollars a year
for the for the portion my tax portion
of maintaining the roads
and if you keep me from driving on this
road then you have stolen one 365th
of
the hundred dollars that i paid for the
road
i cannot
presume the sponsor's intent but it
appeared that that was
what he was indicating
thank you
representative gutzer did you want to
direct your question to this witness
what's that okay
anybody else would like to
test a question to testify
thank you very much thank you for the
opportunity to speak
as anybody else want to testify on this
bill
i'm going to close
the hearing on
12 house bill 1267
and i'll ask for the blue sheet
thank you
our next bill is going to be 1272 and
that one is at 11 30.
so if you want to take a little break
now 10 minutes we'll be good
catherine heck
is opposed to it
okay
uh julie yeah julian which is is in the
corner she is okay and um
not sh
i see him here okay
let's see you
um sorry
oh
one
representatives
so this is
oh
foreign
um
oh was that last time
seemed to run out
surprised
really
oh
are you ready
yes
just
oh
i just
yes
right
oh
so
thank you very much
chair and members of the committee thank
you for hearing my testimony i'm
representative harvey boglia
representing the towns of tilton and
samerton in belknap
district 4.
this this bill um house bill 17
12 72 sorry it's my first bill
deals with rsa 14
147 colon 1
which is
deals with the health officer authority
specifically the authority to create
regulation in town
the issue is that this statute is overly
broad
it's vague
and it does not match what is already
the existing guidance
and principles from the new hampshire
dhhs
health officer manual
so i'd just like to i consider it a
housekeeping bill
and
we'll just kind of go over it
see if you have any questions
um things to know is this bill and or
the amendment that i've presented i
emailed it to all the committee members
and
apologize for the late email
you should also have a paper copy
we'll fix the issue and it does not
impact
in any way the current duties
and authorities of the health officer in
their day-to-day
regulation you know what they are doing
from day to day in towns
briefly what does a health officer do
firstly a health office has
three hours of required training as far
as i know to to become a health officer
in a town
i have included
the role of the health officer which you
should see in your packet of information
which is taken from the dhhs website
and also a subsection of that
of that manual which is communicable or
infectious diseases
but in sure the health officer does do a
lot of things i'm i'm somewhat familiar
with it
but you know everything from bed bugs to
dealing with housing
restaurant
safety food safety
nuisances what they call nuisances
you know
septic drains
um
any kind of pests rodents that it's a
big list so i can understand why
uh when this
certain portion of the health officer
regulation was written that it was
written as as follows and if you indulge
me
it is
just a certain portion of the health
officer
statute
and it says
the health officers of towns may make
regulations for the prevention and
removal of nuisances
and such other regulations relating to
the public health as in their judgment
the health and safety of the people
require
a little open-ended um
so
and then it just you know describes how
that's done
which i'll take effect when approved by
the selectmen recorded by the town clerk
and published in some newspaper printed
in the town or when copies have been
posted in two or more public places in
town
there is no requirement for a public
hearing
usually
as far as i know when you make
ordinances in regulation in town
the legislative body of the town gets to
have a say in that
so i assume they mean emergency
uh this is pertaining to emergencies
so in my research
i have found that the state of vermont
has a
quite a bit a more robust
language here that provides
for some grievance um
for somebody who may have had an
ordinance passed say against their
property
specifically
or
or for the public to to to have some
sort of check
so there's no check here is the problem
um let me see my notes here
okay
so i have um
i've got the amendment here
um and i understand that uh the nhma is
not happy with some of this
but i am willing to change it so what i
did was take if you look at your
amendment
um sections b and c
are verbatim from the vermont
health officer code
it kind of limits it and clarifies
what it is that they
that the health officer
may do
it's
pertains to emergency health orders
which is why i what i
assume that they meant by
you know
147 here
and then
in section c
it says a person to whom an emergency
health order is directed shall be given
the opportunity for a hearing within
five business days of the issuance of
such an order
a person who is in full compliance with
the emergency health order may request
and shall be granted an extension of
this hearing date if the emergency order
was issued by the commissioner of health
and human services uh
services
under rsa 147 colon two such a hearing
shall be in front of the commissioner
uh et cetera et cetera so um there is a
an opportunity for rebuttal
because in theory
an ordinance could be passed
that is directed at someone's property
and so
some recourse should be given
the next thing that i've done is in this
amendment
is take language that is directly
from the role of the health officer
guidance
from the health officer manual that is
online
and it specifies what sort of things so
you'll see under
number six
what sort of
things the health officer may
pass ordinance about or regulation about
garbage insects unsanitary living
conditions rodents and safe drinking
water inspections
so that is
taken directly
from the health officer manual
on
page three
under
uh rsa 147 colon three
um
so it's it's already so these are items
that i've added that are already in the
manual
so to get on to communicable diseases
and their role in all of this
according to the communicable diseases
or infectious diseases part of the
manual
and you've seen that i highlighted in
yellow the role of the health officer is
always
to support the commissioner
they shall report to the commissioner
about communicable disease
they shall
they under rsa 141
dash c colon 5 assist the commissioner
of dhhs
may assist
the
dphs infectious disease control program
may assist
the program with the control of
identified illness
it's assisting
but not solving communicable disease
problems for the town
i
they don't have the training for that
but
working with the commissioner
is perfectly
appropriate in this case
so um i think i'll take some questions
does anybody have any uh questions for
representative
representatives davis
thank you
mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question can you define
for me please what repugnant to the new
hampshire constitution means oh thank
you defines repugnant thank you
representatives davis for pointing that
out to me um
i'm a bit nervous my first bill
um this
representative davis is referring to
the section uh starting at number nine
of the amendment
um
provided however that no by-law or
ordinance made by a local health officer
shall be repugnant to the constitution
or laws of the state
representative why i put that in there
is because it's already in
our
sister ordinance to this one for cities
and for cities
so you'll see later when i visit you
again
um
that
when we deal with the same ordinance uh
same statute i'm sorry for cities
that clause is in their verbatim
so um
i'm trying to keep it consistent
and that is why i put that in there
but i am happy to take it out if if it
makes no sense
to people but um as i was
speaking with others i am
open to
amending this
and
i don't know if i stated but
i put in here starting at number 11.
such bylaws and ordinances shall take
effect and be enforced from the time
adopted for not longer than 10 days
without the sanction or confirmation of
any other authority
so um
and then i go and talk about clear and
present danger which is a legal term
but apparently that doesn't um nh nhma
will point out that that applies to
first amendment rights
i am happy to take those two things out
the
10 days
and the clear and present danger because
what i did was define more carefully and
narrowly
at the top
under line six
what it is exactly a health officer
should be making ordinance about
it's
limited to those
such things garbage insects etc
which is taken right from their manual
as far as what they do and then if
things need to be added later
than that they can be
but um
he said i i will take that out if the
committee finds it just onerous
okay are there any other questions
representative ian
thank you chairman and thank you
representative um i'm looking at this
list of things that health officers of
towns may make emergency regulations for
and i notice a conspicuous uh
miss thing missing which is communicable
disease
is that intentional
i'm sorry representative are you i'm
looking looking line six oh line six
okay where it says that health officers
of towns may make emergency regulations
for the prevention and removal of
nuisances
such as garbage insects on sanitary
living conditions rodents and safe
drinking water inspections
but it looks to me like the communicable
diseases is part of this
in the handbook so is the elimination of
communicable diseases
um intentional here
well thank you for the question
representative van um
i
it is
only intentional in that
it conflicts already with the health
officer manual
which does not state anywhere
that
a health officer may make regulations
for a town
about communicable diseases but has a
supportive role
to the commissioner as you would expect
a small town
to um have a city may be different now
the cities have a whole separate
different um
a set of they have board of they have
boards of health and
it's a more robust system but
from what i see
small towns towns now aren't set up for
the management of regular regulating
townspeople
in addition not just regulating but
without any sort of public hearing
or any kind of check or balance
whatsoever
and so there's a possibility to
to put in here communicable diseases in
some way but tell you tell me what way
that would be because
it's not exactly clear how how far they
can go
thank you oh i hope that answers your
question
uh representative majori
you do okay
thank you mistake sorry about that
that's okay thank you so much uh both of
you and and thank you representative for
taking my question um in the um
information that we got from the
department of health and human services
one of the
comments and and i'm gonna preface this
with
and i will ask a follow-up question do
you not feel that being this specific of
naming these um items
that there could be unintended
consequences of something that we forget
such as what was put in the letter
that i don't you probably have not seen
it but it says failure of septic tank is
another common nuisance
that may spread from one property to
another creating a health hazard that
can affect water and air quality
so by being so
specific of listing what the
quote-unquote nuisances are
that we could forget something and
in the end have an unintended
consequences by this
you for the question representative um
the the issue is that you can have an
unattended consequence for from having
a
giving the health officer godlike powers
to pass any regulation whatsoever and if
you read it carefully
in any
such any other regulations relating to
public health as their judgment the
people require
that's extremely broad but
to your point though
septic issues are something that health
officers deal with all the time and it's
already in their purview
to
deal with those issues
on a case-by-case basis this ordinance
this section
of amending this part
only deals with them passing an
ordinance which would affect the entire
town
but it doesn't
prevent them from dealing with septic
issues which they do every single day
and it's it's already in the statutes
elsewhere how they deal with that it's a
state statute
that that they would be enforcing go
ahead when you follow up yes
and i'll try to make it quick um i i
guess if if it's in the statute um i
understand what you're what you're
saying but i have a concern that we have
this letter that that basically says
that this is omitted and that
this is part of what they define as a
nuisance
um so i guess mike my question is
should it not also be listed under under
your nuisances
and then again
because they brought this up the
unintended consequences of
limiting what they could possibly do if
something like this came up well i
thank you very much i believe unsanitary
living conditions would
be that would cover septic
thank you
thanks
are there any other questions majority
thank you mr chair i don't i don't know
that i've properly formed this question
but i'm i'm having a hard time
reconciling the word emergency with all
of the other definitions
that we have
all the other instances that we have
drafted here or that you have come up
with here
so
by who is defining what agency what what
what anybody who is defining the word
emergency
and how is it reconciled against garbage
for instance and insect for instance i i
think of a bill that we just heard this
morning about composting and if for some
reason
if that bill were to pass and we would
have pests
would that be an emergency situation i i
just don't i'm trying to figure out how
they will define if that's an emergency
sorry that it's not a mature question
it's it's i haven't formulated it in my
head yet
um thank you representative i
um
i guess it doesn't matter if that word
emergency is in there or not um
but i i was taking it i guess i what i
did was i took it from vermont's
regulations
to make it
so that people could understand why
uh sort of the usual route for passing a
town ordinance
would be superseded by this
shortcut
it's it it does make makes no difference
whether it's in there or not because
it's it's a it's a way it's a
it's a method for
uh regulation to be passed whether it's
um
you call it an emergency some people may
call an emergency others may say
where's the emergency
so um
if that is what's hanging us up is is
the word emergency not being defined i
would happily take it out
thank you
representative
yes
yes thank you for taking my question
um
would this bill have any implications
considering our current status
of
previously we had a health emergency
declared by the governor
in the state of new hampshire because of
covet
could a
person who is a health officer
for
instance declare
unilaterally declare
some sort of health emergency
and for instance
require everyone to wear masks
24 hours a day that sort of thing
would this have those implications
thank you representative um i i believe
that's what this bill is
in amendment is trying seeking to
prevent um
one of the things but not i don't see
and as a on a personal note i don't have
any issue with the
the mask mandates that are in place now
it's it's
really not about that but about perhaps
curfews or
i don't want to list all the things but
if you look at the
state of massachusetts website you'll
have different types of mask ordinances
in different towns and cities
that change from day to day we have
two or three towns already that have
mask ordinances that had them that
cancel them that are bringing them back
um
i've gone to the website and i can't
even find them the mask ordinance on the
town of hanover's website so i wouldn't
know
if i was visiting
whether i needed to wear a mask it's not
even on there so that is why we're not a
home rule state
ladies and gentlemen we're
trying seeking to avoid uh piecemeal
regulation town to town
we've carved out
an exception for cities which have a
board of health and they have a separate
rsa that deals with just this which we
can address later that they they have
more broad powers to regulate their own
city they have a board of health etc but
as far as all the smaller towns
it isn't it somewhat of a nightmare to
have
different ordinances all across the town
when we have a governor who can declare
a state of emergency in a mass mandate
for instance
and that is just one example i certainly
don't want to
limit this discussion to just mass
because it is certainly not about that
but about
something
that we should think about for the next
hundred years as far as
what sort of things we want them to
address and i would suggest that the
health officer would be grateful not to
have to be responsible for communicable
diseases
in their community
given their limited
training
i hope that answers that
representative
uh thank you um mr chairman and um
you you said something that kind of
piqued me when you said we have a
governor that
would would make these
decisions etc um
perhaps i i'm wrong but i i live in the
city of nashville we do have a
mask mandate
and if i'm not mistaken the governor
kind of
turned it over to the municipalities to
determine what was best for there
would this not kind of take that away he
you would be putting it
are you directing it to be put on the
shoulder of the governor to have to
decide what is best for the entire state
when he very clearly made a comment
what's good for the north is not
necessarily good for the south or the
east and the west
he would have to make a decision for the
entire or she would have to make a
decision for the entire state
wouldn't that kind of put a little bit
more burden
when he knows or she knows in fact that
each area is very different
thank you for the question
representative and that's exactly right
i believe the governor pointed to this
ordinance
was he passing the buck i don't know but
um
that is perfectly fine if we had boards
of health in each town
um that the problem again is that
there's no limit
to what sort of
things what what how far they can take
any mandate now i'm not talking about uh
just mass mandate but any
any health health mandate curfews or
vaccine mandates um where's the limit
here in the in this language
to what they can do it's so open-ended
it's it's in their judgment
it's a person with three hours of
training that's a lay person and they
work with the board of selectmen
uh to come up with an ordinance
none of them have any medical training
so
why wouldn't you allow the
people living in the town at least a
public hearing
thank you representative stavis
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my follow-up question
in how many communities in new hampshire
are there health officers with
relatively little to no medical training
do you have those statistics
no
i don't i just know the ones that i have
know of um
offhand
anecdotally
thank you for taking my follow-up
then can you tell me upon what basis you
make the statement that town health
officers
have limited training or none at all
uh representative thank you i
would like to clarify that i did not say
that they have
no training at all
but they have three hours of training
and it's
to to
you know to to to address what's in this
this manual
and what's in this manual
clearly states
that what the commissioner and dhhs
would like them to do is support
um the health officer liaison liaison
unit
it's it's all over here
spelled out i don't know how much more
clearly it has to be but
um it's all about assisting
that why i don't know why we wouldn't
have we have an epidemiologist
we have a
state department
and they have experts and they're well
aware they have medical doctors that can
tell us if we need
what what we need and i would like to
defer to them
okay uh representative
thank you representative and thank you
for taking my question
um in addition to
some of the concerns raised by my
colleagues regarding the
application of what's or the definition
of repugnant or
emergency i also have a question about
on line nine it says
without the sanction or confirmation of
any other authority
is that local authority
elected authority appointed authority
state authority national authority it
seems as though that would really allow
the health officer to
you know are they defining who their
authority is
oh thank you uh representative wrong
i have highlighted in yellow i hope your
copy also has it highlighted in yellow
i meant to remove that and i'm terribly
sorry um
but i sent it off and i did not remove
that um
but it is my intention to remove this
because it is vague and
um i basically put it in originally as a
place keeping um
when i first wrote the bill but i am i
am
i i aim to take that out
um and i as i stated before i can also
take about
take out
the repugnant um to the constitution we
could take that out but i i just really
the only reason why i put that in there
is to be consistent with the the other
ordinance about cities and towns
to me it's it's irregardless but i the
stuff in yellow that i highlighted i
will take out
sorry about that
representative
i think so thank you mr chair and thank
you again for taking uh another question
you've i i understand part a of parent a
uh about controlling the ability for
creating that ordinance i get that
and i understand b and c parents b and
parent c about issuing the order and
then having recourse
what i'm trying to reconcile and hoping
there's an
easy answer that i'm missing is why are
they all together
could aren't those kind of separate
things because the order
in order for an emergent problem may be
isolated but the top portion of this
seems to be more focused on what may be
a a more general emergency does that
make any sense could could these be
parsed into two separate issues or two
separate amendments
i don't see a problem with that
representative yeah thank you
okay um are there any other questions
was there other people that do have to
testify and i think that uh
this representative has been through
quite a bit here so
you're all set
thank you very much thank you very much
and i'm going to call um
nat grace
from the new hampshire municipal
authority
thank you mr chair nate grays from the
new hampshire municipal association
we oppose the bill as a as originally
written um and
uh the amendment i haven't had time to
look at but my
belief is i would at least as written
we're we're opposing it
my understanding from the sponsor's
testimony today is that she intends to
remove
essentially the
bolded italic portion beginning in line
nine with provided through
uh
line 14 ending with clear and present
danger if you've read my written
testimony that was much of what we
objected to as that was
basically the original bill
um
so i do want to address a couple other
issues that have come up today
i
agree that the phrase emergency doesn't
make much sense in this statute
as this committee will probably recall
last year we had house bill 79 which was
a fairly extensive rewrite of the health
officer statutes
in part and imposed that three-hour
training requirement
and it was really done in response to
some long-term issues that had been
identified both in the health officer
side and on dhhs's side
in order to make those two
basic units of government function
better together
and really the local health officer's
authority to issue any regulations
relating to the public health as in
their judgment
the health and safety that people
require is designed to address local
issues
so statewide issues are obviously
addressed by the legislature and by
rule-making authority at dhhs but local
issues such as bed bug infestations
or you know bears getting into garbage
cans etc they don't require a state
response they require local response
and therefore this is a broad statute
and it gives local authorities some
gives local authorities the authority to
deal with those local issues
as far as the uh limiting of the scope
of that authority is i think it's
possible that we could be overlooking
some issues and i'm i'm
believe dhhs's letter pointed that out
that's a certainly a concern
because i don't know all possible issues
that might come up that a local health
officer would have to deal with
um
realistically it's going to be whatever
comes up in their community
because more often than not how they
receive information is someone in their
community has a problem whether that's
rats coming from their neighbor's house
or whether that's they went to a hotel
in their bed bugs or
whatever the case may be you know the
septic system is overflowing
and they report that to a town official
the town official contacts the local
health officer
and in many cases
um you know that the health officer
especially if it's a full-time position
they have degrees in public health um so
they're very well credentialed
individuals serving as public health
officers in many municipalities
i've talked to a number of them over the
past couple of days
and they
that's what they've studied many of them
have advanced degrees in that
and really the purpose of that
three-hour training from last year's
hb 79 was in order to provide a
best practices type of information to
health officers because they might have
uh that public health training if
they're a larger municipality or if
they're a smaller municipality like a
municipality of 2000 people you know
they're not going to have a full-time
health officer they probably don't have
to deal with a lot of those issues very
frequently it's probably going to be a
select board member or someone else
who's already serving often a long-term
serving
member of the municipal government
who has to do this on a case-by-case
basis so you know though they receive a
report that you know somebody's a
hoarder or something like that and the
health officers called in to help deal
with that help navigate them through the
mental health uh
service process
um
and to deal with kind of the aftermath
of what happens there
and
so
while those individuals may not have
advanced degrees
they're going to be looking at these
common everyday things which are covered
in the health officers guide and that's
really the purpose of that guidebook
in order to help them with those common
issues and of course since we have
revised the statutes they now have a
better and more
robust ability to contact dhhs
experts there as well as health officers
and other municipalities
to ask for best practices and advice
so i don't think it's necessary to
change that authority
as far as representative majorie's
question about
subsections b and c
it appears
it appears like one of the focuses of
this amendment
is to
deal with
some sort of emergency health order that
might be issued through a state like a
quarantine order or something like that
that's not something a local health
officer would do
they might be directed by dhhs to assist
in some capacity and there are other
statutes related to that
but that's not something they would do
on their own it's not something that
would be appropriate to be addressed in
this statute
i'm happy to take questions
are there any questions from mr grace
i see none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
i'd like to call uh matt
okay helene very good thank you very
much
thank you um
good morning chairman dolan and members
of the committee my name is matt kaling
and i represent
dhhs division of public health services
as a brief background i have a few
decades of experience in public health
inspections and training i now supervise
a small program that provides technical
assistance to one part-time person
who provides support for over 300 health
officers across the state the program
responds to hundreds of inquiries a year
to assess and solve local health
problems with the help of the local
health officer in short we work to
ensure that health office are ready to
address sanitary conditions in
homeschools day care facilities and
other locations um committee members
have a copy of the testimony and i'll
just try to summarize some brief points
from that now
there is a new amendment on the table
i've just started to kind of review that
and better understand it it needs some
further review we came here to provide
information dhhs yet need to oppose it
based on the this amendment um that's
been presented
um we're concerned about a couple
aspects of the bill and let me copy
those now
um in regards to news health nuisances
currently local officers are provided
authority under rsa 147 and it's broad
authority where they may make
regulations um so what is a public
health nuisance um often it's a waste
product it's a pest it's a noxious agent
that can move from one property to
another that's what makes it a public
health problem within your home that's
more of a private issue a private health
issue
common examples that people have
mentioned include rubbish and biological
waste from people and animals septic
failures pest and bed bug infestations
the role the health officer is important
to dhhs they're part of the local
community they know their neighbors and
they can make informed decisions about
when and how to respond to health
hazards that are out there
i think the existing law works very well
even as being as broad as it is it
provides a lot of flexibility to health
officers and the department receives
very few complaints about local health
officers or the codes that are there
under this law there's an existing
process to ensure the codes are
appropriate and addressed and address
local concerns
the law states that all local codes must
be approved by the selectmen and there
are recorded and announced via public
notices
we do need to avoid confusion the
department believes that local
ordinances are already reviewed by
municipal attorneys and have the best
qualifications and i realize now
that the representative mentioned she
was planning to remove
the issues around
constitutionality and also remove the
runs about limiting 10 days unless
there's confirmation by another
authority so that may have been resolved
but the proposed language does not
provide
a clear understanding of dangerous
situation versus injurious situation
which is currently included in rsa 147
colon 3 relative to inspections and
complaints
the burden on dhhs in order to implement
the bill the department will need to
collaborate with many partners
and the health officers association and
the municipal association to determine
how the changes may limit the current
authority the department would also need
to change our training curriculum to
interpret how these changes might
affect implementation of rsa 147.
um
you know as you know the committee
passed hb 79 last year this committee
did or didn't pass it but passed it out
of committee and was signed into law the
law improved training and support for
health officers so we feel like day by
day year by year we're trying to improve
how they can do their job
the issue is brought up around they
don't have medical training they don't
need medical training it's wonderful if
we have a doctor or a nurse because
usually they're highly competent but
really we want them to have training in
sanitation and environmental health
right how things move between properties
how people deal with them at a
population level that's something that
comes up in medical training for doctors
and nurses so we feel like we're heading
in the right track to get that done
in closing i want to thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony today
and i'm available to address any
questions that you might have for the
department
in this issue
does anybody have any questions for this
mr colleen
i see none
and thank you very much
is there anybody else who would like to
testify on this bill
okay i see none um can i have the blue
sheets and i do have electronic
testimony
of uh 1270 house bill 1272 uh support
176 opposed to 42.
176 in support
and opposed 42.
on the blue sheet we have
um one two three four five
six
uh we have
um six in favor and one against
uh it's 1272. we'll move around
um i do have uh before i close this out
i'm going to
let you know that i have some more uh
information on the other bills but as of
right now i'm going to close the hearing
on house bill 1272.
okay thank you very much for attending
today i appreciate you coming okay
um
i have remote testimony on house bill
we have 35 in support of that
and zero opposed
which one was that that was uh house
bill 1406
1406.
and
the next one i have testimony electronic
testimony on is house bill one zero five
five
i have four in support
four opposed
everybody get that
and the last one house bill 1081
we have three in support and 18 opposed
and one more sorry
um and this will be house bill 1267
we have zero in support and 17 opposed
yes
mr chair mr chair could you please
repeat
the um
accounts for
house bill one four zero six as well as
one two seven
one two seven two one four oh six is 35
in support and zero opposed
and
what do you say one
two seven two
seven six
where are you
ah
you sure it wasn't one two seven you
wanted one two seven two
okay that was support 176
to oppose 42.
anybody want to look at them they're
right here
okay next monday we have uh uh what is
it the executive uh committee
i believe
we're gonna hear house bill 16 55 i
think
initially at 10 o'clock
uh i mean nine o'clock i'm sorry
um
yes uh house house bill 1665 at nine
o'clock and then ten o'clock we're going
to have exactly mr mr chairman uh
session and we're going to hear all the
bills that we had on the 13th
house bill 106.9 did you have a count on
that one 106 9.
i don't know
i think the pages get stuck together so
let's see what we got
106.9 oh yeah this is support on 106.9
is zero
and opposed two
thank you all for coming in today i
appreciate it
um i will make an announcement for tom
he had surgery today and he is out and
doing fine
so
that's how i get stuck in this chair
everybody bundy
yes
right
oh
you